[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días aquí en france 24 este
es un magacín informativo 100 dedicado
al continente africano mi nombre de
liliana valencia que damos una mirada en
profundidad a los hechos de actualidad
de la semana en la cuna de la humanidad
un barco de titánicas proporciones
encallado en el canal de suez en egipto
generó graves traumatismos en el
comercio mundial al impedir que
centenarios de buques de carga
atravesarán el paso que conecta al mar
mediterráneo con el mar rojo las
pérdidas ocasionadas por el incidente
son multimillonarias
el primer ministro de etiopía viaje me
da anunció el retiro de las fuerzas
militares editorial de la región norteña
de tigre donde se vive un fuerte
conflicto armado desde noviembre de 2020
el premio nobel de la paz reconoció que
se han cometido crímenes de lesa
humanidad durante los enfrentamientos
y sigue en el continente aplicaron no
lidera las cifras mundiales de muertos y
contagios por kobe 19 si es uno de los
más rezagados en términos de vacunación
sólo uno de los 55 países del continente
se acerca al 3 por ciento de la
población vacunada tenemos análisis
desde angola
[Música]
iniciamos con la información aquí en
áfrica siete días y empezamos con temas
económicos porque la semana estuvo
marcada por el bloqueo del canal del
suez en egipto que conecta el mar
mediterráneo con el mar rojo esta es una
de las rutas marítimas más concurridas
del mundo y orgullo nacional de egipto
un enorme portacontenedor con bandera
panameña y propietario japonés que va
atrapado en este punto clave en la ruta
marítima entre asia y europa tras
prender la capacidad de maniobra
autoridad marítima de varios países
unieron esfuerzos para desbloquear este
importante paso comercial
el canal de suez es fundamental porque
mueve alrededor del 12 por ciento del
comercio a nivel mundial además es la
vía fluvial de unos 50 barcos cada día
que representan mercancías por 3 mil
millones de dólares las consecuencias
económicas de este bloqueo afecta no
solo a egipto sino a naciones de europa
asia y áfrica cuyos barcos se ven
obligados a esperar durante días o dar
una vuelta muchísimo más larga y costosa
al menos 200 barcos llevar esperando
durante días después de que el taiwanés
ever given encallara en diagonal a causa
de los fuertes vientos veamos el informe
una ballena varada así define la
compañía de rescate al barco ever given
que quedó atrapado en diagonal
interrumpiendo el tráfico de mercancías
del canal de suez debido al temporal de
viento y arena el suceso ha dejado en
espera a decenas de barcos en las filas
más largas vistas en décadas
el propietario japonés se disculpó
mientras que el gobierno nipón dio
información sobre el estado del rescate
en este momento el tráfico a lo largo
del canal de suez se ha interrumpido por
el incidente y las autoridades locales
están trabajando para resolver el
problema utilizando remolcadores es
habitual el en calle de barcos en el
canal de suez cuando son remolcados a su
llegada aunque suelen ser rápidamente
liberados sin embargo el barco de 400
metros quedó en un difícil tramo de un
solo carril y varios países se unieron
en el esfuerzo por removerlo y evitar
peores implicaciones económicas tres
canales el canal de suez es
potencialmente el canal más importante
del mundo y lo ha sido durante más de
100 años en realidad es muy fácil de
explicar o atraviesas el canal de suez o
recorres el camino
largo hasta el final al sur alrededor de
áfrica
eso es un desvío de al menos 5000 km
suez es un canal artificial ubicado en
egipto de 193 kilómetros que conecta el
mar mediterráneo y el mar rojo fue
inaugurado en 1869 por ahí pasan el 30%
de los contenedores del mundo y el 12
por ciento del comercio mundial también
es el punto donde va el 80% del petróleo
desde medio oriente a europa aunque
también afecta entre otros a india y
china- principales importadores y
seguimos en egipto porque al menos 32
personas fallecieron y 66 resultaron
heridas tras el choque de dos trenes en
la localidad de thatta en la provincia
sureña de soja según un comunicado del
ministerio más de 30 ambulancias
transportaron a las víctimas a varios
hospitales cercanos de la provincia
situada en el valle del nilo donde las
vías ferroviarias son viejas y están en
mal estado el último gran accidente de
este tipo se produjo el 27 de febrero de
2019 en el que murieron 22 personas y al
menos 40 resultaron heridas en la
estación central de la cca
el primer ministro de etiopía anunció
que las fuerzas militares eritreas se
retiraran de la región norteña de tigre
en disputa armada del pasado mes de
noviembre unas declaraciones que llegan
después de que el mandatario admitiera
que se han cometido crímenes de guerra
durante los meses de enfrentamientos
pero sin atribuir responsabilidades
veamos
luego de meses de conflicto y tensiones
constantes el ejército eritreo acordó
retirar sus tropas de la disputada
región de tigre en el norte de etiopía
fronteriza con eritrea así lo anunció el
primer ministro etíope había hammett que
esta semana tras meses de negación
admitió la presencia de militares
eritreos en el territorio desde
noviembre de 2020 con la escalada de los
ataques dos más el gobierno de eritrea
ha aceptado retirar sus tropas de la
frontera etíope la fuerza de defensa
nacional de etiopía se hará cargo de la
vigilancia de las zonas fronterizas con
efecto inmediato el premio nobel de la
paz etíope no informó de cuántos
soldados eritreos se movilizaron pero
testigos estiman que podrían ser miles
además reconoció que durante los
enfrentamientos con las fuerzas rebeldes
tigrillas se cometieron crímenes de
guerra sin aceptar responsabilidades
tanto el ejército eritreo como el etíope
han sido señalados de saqueos masacres y
violaciones
la gente fue asesinada por las balas las
armas pesadas en los tanques disparaban
y las casas fueron quemadas en este
momento la gente huyó
si los atrapaban los mataban era el
ejército eritreo
este viernes naciones unidas- consiguió
entrar a los campos de refugiados
eritreos en tigres por primera vez desde
noviembre
durante una misión conjunta en la zona
con la oficina de coordinación de
asuntos humanitarios de la onu
encontramos ambos campamentos
completamente destruidos y todas las
instalaciones humanitarias saqueadas y
vandalizadas acnur está profundamente
preocupada por el bienestar de los
refugiados eritreos que residían allí
todos han huido de los campos
el conflicto en etiopía estalló el
pasado 4 de noviembre desde entonces
casi un millón de etíopes y refugiados
eritreos han huido al vecino sudán
hablamos ahora el coi 19 y de la
advertencia que hacen las autoridades
sanitarias de las diferentes naciones
africanas sobre una posible guerra por
las vacunas ante la demora en los envíos
de las dosis
si bien el mecanismo kóvacs de la o&m se
ha entregado una cantidad considerable
en varios países estas están lejos de
ser suficientes para promover campañas
masivas de vacunación
en este mapa podemos ver como los países
con mayor capacidad adquisitiva la
mayoría en el norte del mundo ya avanzan
activamente sus campañas de vacunación
mientras que gran parte del continente
africano apenas está recibiendo los
primeros cargamentos de los 55 países
africanos solo marruecos ha demonizado a
más del 3 por ciento de su población
sobre el tema hablamos con el médico
colombiano jose francisco fernández
quien desde luanda la capital de angola
nos explicó el panorama general de la
vacunación en el continente africano
algunos países como sudáfrica donde yo
resido que ha sido la nación más
afectada del continente por el cob y 19
también está buscando vacunas contra el
virus a través de acuerdos bilaterales y
dónde
la vacuna sirva contra su propia
variante
y esto ha creado creado un retraso aún
mayor pues los millones de dosis de
vacuna de astrazéneca que iban para
áfrica del sur ya no se pudieron recibir
al considerar que la vacuna no es la más
adecuada para protegerlos contra esa
variante este continente no solamente ha
recibido ses en cantidades muy limitadas
sino que las ha venido recibiendo mucho
más tarde que el resto del mundo al
menos hay unos 10 países africanos que
todavía no reciben vacunas entre ellos
tanzania burundi eritrea camerún chad y
esto obviamente genera preocupación
entre todos nosotros hablamos ahora de
derechos de la población lgtb y en el
continente africano porque si bien el un
alto porcentaje de los países la
homosexualidad sigue siendo considerado
un delito
sudáfrica se destaca a nivel mundial
como uno de los países que genera más
legislación en pro de la diversidad
desde ciudad del cabo nuestro
corresponsal salem fayad nos entregó
previamente detalles de esta información
sudáfrica es el único país del
continente africano donde es legal el
matrimonio igualitario y después de la
caída de la parte y la nueva
constitución sudafricana sería la
primera en el mundo en prohibir la
discriminación a los homosexuales
más adelante en 2006 sudáfrica se
convertiría en el quinto país en aprobar
el matrimonio para personas del mismo
sexo durante la parte de la
homosexualidad criminaliza dic hasta
quedar hasta con siete años de prisión
pero hoy en día en áreas urbanas
especialmente aquí la ciudad del cabo y
especialmente aquí en el barrio de green
point es donde nos encontramos ahora se
presenta una amplia oferta para la
comunidad lgtb del mundo incluso se
ofrecen paquetes turísticos que buscan
atraer a miembros de esta comunidad a
visitar la ciudad sin embargo en las
áreas menos favorecidas especialmente en
la periferia urbana se presentan aún
grandes desafíos para la comunidad lgtb
y sobre todo cuando hablamos de
episodios de violencia homofóbica y de
altas tasas de vih sudáfrica también es
un centro receptor de inmigrantes el fpv
y de países de áfrica subsahariana donde
la homosexualidad es criminalizada entre
los cuales se encuentran sin bagua
uganda y tanzania y pasamos al mundo
digital porque el reconocido
internacionalista y activista experto de
migración es nacido en
sanz y la dan lanzó recientemente un
podcast destinado a difundir aspectos
fundamentales de la verdadera historia
de áfrica y generar conciencia sobre la
relevancia de la cuna de la humanidad en
la conciencia colectiva global áfrica en
un clic ya está disponible en las
plataformas digitales desde españa la
dan nos con todos los pormenores del
proyecto
lanzamos el proyecto de podcast áfrica
en un clip para acercar un poco más el
continente africano al público
hispanohablante tiene como objetivo
cambiar narrativas contar la auténtica
historia de áfrica lejos de los tópicos
y las imágenes que los medios de
comunicación nos hemos comprado hablar
de áfrica teniendo en cuenta su
complejidad y su diversidad
invocando temática como historia la
geopolítica las relaciones
internacionales y algunas curiosidades
también el continente a los que no nos
han acostumbrado es una herramienta no
solo de aprendizaje sino el
empoderamiento también para la nueva
generación que somos para verte a lo
largo de la historia ha habido grandes
mujeres y hombres africanos que
contribuyeron al avance de la humanidad
a través de sus obras y eso para
nosotros y nosotras en búsqueda muchas
veces de diferentes es sumamente
importante
lanzaremos un episodio de menos de 10
minutos cada semana y estará en spotify
y en todas las plataformas de escucha y
finalizamos con música hecha para
conectar a briga con su diáspora en
américa latina' esta vez el grupo afro
colombiano chocquibtown galardonado en
varias ocasiones con el premio grammy se
unió con el artista nigeriano ministro
la canción se titula maría y hará parte
del nuevo álbum de ministro se trata de
una composición lograda entre ambas
agrupaciones que surgido en el consejo
panafricano un espacio creado justamente
para unir a áfrica con sus diásporas a
nivel internacional los dejamos con esta
buena música pero ustedes también pueden
continuar con más en nuestra página web
france24 puntocom nos vemos más adelante
con más información quédense esté
esperando 24
tienen mi cupo de alegría y quién lo
dijo
que dejaste la conocía bailando de noche
y de día y que me tiene loco loco loco
casting y repite él otra vez y que me
tienen todos los patines con costura
lleva mezcla de letra m 9 y repítelo
otra vez vamos a los modelos passat de
los amigos esto me tiene en este así no
puedo esperar para seguir tu cuerpo
[Música]
maría arias
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
y
así es
qué voy a hacer magia te pienso todo el
día y mi corazón
ya tiene muy buenos
[Música]